again i mean
look at joe joe is more powerful than
cnn and msnbc and fox all put together
that gives me like immense inspiration
yeah like he created the space
for me to succeed and i told him that
when i met him i was like
dude like i listened to his podcast when
i was like young
and like and i remember like when i got
to meet him and
all that and i told him this on this pod
i was like i didn't know people were
millions were willing to listen to a guy
talk about chimps for
three straight hours including me i
didn't know that
yeah he's one of those people yeah me
too i learned something about myself
yeah
yeah and so by creating that space i'd
be like wait
there's a hunger here like he showed us
all the way
and none of us will ever again be as
famous as rogan because he was the first
and that's fine because he created the
umbrella ecosystem for us all to thrive
that is where i see like a great amount
of hope
within that story yeah and the cool
thing he also supports that ecosystem
he's such a he's so
so generous one of the things he paved
the way on for me
is to to show that you can just be
honest publicly honest yes
and uh not jealous of other people's
success but instead of being supportive
and
and all those kinds of things just like
loving towards others he's been an
inspiration
i mean uh to the comics community
i think there are a bunch of uh before
that
i think there were all a bunch of
competitive haters towards each other
yeah
and now he's like just injected love
yeah you know
they're like they're still like many are
still resistant but they're like they
can't
help it because he's such a huge voice
he like forces them to be
like loving towards each other and the
same i tried to
one of the reasons i wanted to start
this podcast
was to try to i wanted to be like a uh
do what joe rogan did but for the
scientific community
like my little circle scientific
community of like
like let's support each other yeah well
like avi lope
i would have no idea who he was if it
wasn't for you i mean i assume you put
him in touch with joe
he went on joe's show i had him on my
show like millions of people would have
no idea who he was if it wasn't for you
just by the way in terms of deep state
of government avilo has to do with
aliens you better believe
joe dude the last thing i sent to him
was the american airlines audio
did you see that uh the pilots who were
oh my god dude this is amazing so like
this american airlines flight crew was
over new mexico this happened five or
six days ago
and they the guy comes and goes hey do
you have any targets up here
a large cylindrical object just flew
over me
oh so this happens so this happens yes
then
a guy or like a radio catcher records
this and posts it online
american airlines confirms that this is
authentic audio
and they go all further questions should
be referred to the fbi
so then okay american airlines just
confirmed it's a legitimate transmission
fbi then the faa comes out and says
we were tracking no objects
in the vicinity of this plane at the
time of the transmission so
the only plausible explanation that
online salutes have been able to say is
maybe he saw a leader jet which was
you know using like open source data faa
rule set out
so what was it he saw a large
cylindrical object
while he was mid-flight american
airlines but you can go
online listen to the audio yourself this
is a 100
no [ __ ] transmission confirmed by
american airlines
of a commercial pilot over new mexico
seeing a quote-unquote large cylindrical
object
in the air like i said um when we first
started talking i've never believed
i've never believed more in ufos than
aliens yeah
this is awesome yeah i i i just wish
both the american airlines
fbi and uh government would be more
transparent like there would be voices
i know it sounds ridiculous but the kind
of transparency that you see maybe not
joe rogan he's
he's like overly transparent he's just a
comic really but
just uh i don't know like a podcast from
the fbi
just like being honest like excited
confused
uh i'm sure the car
they're being overly cautious about
their release information i'm sure
there's a lot of information that will
inspire the public
that will inspire trust and institutions
that will not damage
national security like it seems to me
obvious and the reason they're not
sharing it is because of this momentum
of bureaucracy of caution and so on
but there's probably so much cool
information that the government has
the way i almost i wouldn't say it
confirmed it's real
but trump didn't didn't declassify it
like you
know that if there was ever president
that actually wanted to get to the
bottom of it it was him
yeah i mean he didn't declassify it man
and people begged him to i know for a
fact because i pushed
to try and make this happen that some
people did speak to him about it
and he was like no i'm not gonna do it
so he might be afraid uh
that's what i mean though they were
probably all telling them like sir you
can't do this you know all this like wow
and i get that and there's this
legislation written in covad that like
they have six months to release is that
real what is that that was a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i think it's both there's so many
different levels of classification that
people
need to understand i mean look i read
john podesta he was the uh
chief of staff to bill clinton he's a
big ufo guy he
he tried like him and clinton tried to
get some of this information and they
could not get
any of it and they were talking about
the president and the white house chief
of staff at the time
well there's a whole bureaucracy built
just like you're saying with intent you
have to be
like that has to be your focus because
there's a whole bureaucracy built around
secrecy
for probably for a good reason so to get
through to the information
there's a whole like paperwork process
all that kind of stuff you can't just
walk in and get the
unless again with intention that becomes
your thing like
let's revolutionize this thing and then
you get
only so many things uh it's it's sad
that the the bureaucracy
has gotten so bulky um but i think
the hopeful messages from earlier in our
conversation it seems like
a single person can't fix it but if you
hire the right team
it feels like you can can't fix
everything i don't wanna i don't wanna
give people on real estate expectations
you can fix a lot especially in crisis
you can remake america yeah and the
reason i know that is because it's
already happened
twice fdr or in modern history
fdr and jfk sorry fdr and jfk's
assassination
lbj two hyper-competent men
who understood government who understood
personnel and coincidentally were
friends i love this i don't think
actually people
understand this fdr met johnson
three days after he won his congress
his election to congress special
election he was only 29 years old
and he left that meeting and called
somebody and said
this young man is gonna be president of
the united states someday like
even then like what was within him to
understand
and to recognize that and sometimes
johnson as a young member of congress
would come and have breakfast with fdr
like just to the great
political minds of the 20th century just
sitting there
talking like i would give anything to
know what that was happening
you